[Music]
reinventions a little bit difficult to
describe in my life because I've
recently discovered that since
elementary school in my yearbook I said
I want to be a game developer and here
you know 20 years later I'm still being
a game developer so I guess for myself
I'm looking forward to reinventing more
in the future because you know the
industry and everything around this is
constantly changing new technologies are
always coming out so even in my own
personal growth I just want to keep
adapting to the future
I feel like I had the same path as a lot
of other game developers honestly I was
I was 13 years old and I googled game
making program and I found this thing
called game maker and I just kind of
stuck with it right when I graduated
college I actually applied to a bunch of
different game development companies and
I didn't hear back from a single one so
at that point I was like I either have
the choice where I can keep trying and
go work for another game development
company where I'm not having a lot of
success or I can just continue making my
own games and having my own company and
doing my own projects and the company
kind of came along the way is because
you know as a kid you're always like oh
I want to be Nintendo or I want to be
Sega or something so you know I was
asking soft the thing that honestly
interested me the most since I was a kid
was I just liked creating things you
know I'm Gabe Development is sort of a
way for me to create all the things I've
always wanted to do I get to tell
stories I get to make music I get to you
know create scenes and have people feel
a certain way and I also get to work on
the nitty gritty mechanical parts of it
as well so it kind of feels like just
getting to do everything I ever wanted
to do creatively in one complete package
I have faced a little bit of a few
issues at some point or another you know
I had to move back in with the parents
for a bit and then you know I did
groceries and like didn't really have a
very lavish lifestyle for a few years I
kind of just sat in my room and
programmed all the time if I have any
advice to you know starting in the video
game industry the biggest thing is
really the ability to actually you know
persevere through it because making a
video game is such a arduous process so
you really have to sit down and tell
yourself is this something that I really
wanted to vote on my time to and if you
have the perseverance to go through with
it then I think that's an incredible
feat
you